for the fact that Brian was strong-armed
into giving this talk today I sat with
him at breakfast at a quantum school in
Jerusalem in December and we were
talking and it seemed like he was the
perfect person to sort of give this
introductory talk on to people like me
the computer science audience on sort of
the basics of the problems that they
looked at it but an algorithm for
chemistry sometimes when you just hit
the chemistry it goes over my head
I'm really looking forward to this talk
I'm really looking forward to learning a
lot and thank you Brian for taking with
it time to put it together
thank you yeah so thank you all for
being here yeah thanks to the organizers
for a wonderful workshop so yeah so so
let me say I'm not a quantum chemist but
you know I've worked with quantum
chemist for quite a long time applying
quantum computation to quantum chemistry
and so I have a sense of you know what
the the gap is and in language between
you know quantum chemistry and
theoretical computer science and so you
may have heard that quantum chemistry is
one of the most promising applications
of quantum computation and my goal of
this talk is to explain you know what
that means from a computer science
perspective so what the main problems of
interest are and how and why quantum
computers may be useful in helping us so
I'll start with you know a reasonable
explanation of what chemical
hamiltonians are what the problem is
that we care most about solving I'll
very briefly touch on classical
approaches to solving this and then I'll
spend some time talking about how we can
use quantum computers to just solve
so I'll start with you know the very
simple model of the world that is the
starting point of our quantum chemistry
simulations and this is that we have a
set of nuclei somewhere in space
surrounded by a cloud of electrons so we
have these classical nuclei that are
these point charges somewhere in space
none of these black dots in this cartoon
and we have these quantum electrons that
are in this cloud around it and of
course these nuclei are really quantum
mechanical particles but there's so much
more massive than the electrons that
it's a reasonable very good
approximation in this context to model
them as classical it's just these plot
artists and this is known as the
born-oppenheimer approximation but the
same is not true of the electrons you
know there is something about the scale
of the system such that you know we
cannot even qualitatively describe
what's going on without modeling these
electrons as quantum mechanical objects
and of course the specter you neglect
neglect you know relativistic effects
and others but for the purposes of
predicting chemical reactions this this
is the starting point of the model so if
we imagine that we fix a the positions
of the nuclei in space the electrons
will rearrange themselves and we'll get
some effective energy and we can imagine
doing this for every possible
positioning of the nuclei in space and
if we do this we'll get to an energy
function that takes these nuclear
positions and gives us an energy and in
the space of these nuclear coordinates
we'll get this energy landscape this
energy landscape is of interest to us
because it turns out that molecules are
simply local minima in this energy
landscape and chemical reactions are
just movements from one of these local
minima to another and we have you know
complex chemical reaction pathways are
you know pathways through that this
energy landscape and so you know as a
very simple example or consider a
hydrogen molecule we just have these two
nuclei two protons and up two rotational
symmetry all we care about is the
distance between these two
and we get this very simple
one-dimensional energy landscape where
if they're very far apart you know they
don't really see each other when they're
you know on top of each other we have
these very strong repulsion but
somewhere in between there's this sweet
spot where there's a local minimum in
the energy landscape and indeed you know
this is why it makes sense refer to a
thing such as a hydrogen molecule this
is the state that the system is in most
likely you know up to thermal
fluctuations and so you know even if we
could compute this energy function as a
function of the nuclear coordinates
there would still be this hard problem
of exploring this landscape and finding
out where the minima are and pathways
between them but that's not the problem
that I'm going to be focused on in this
talk the problem that I'll be focusing
on in this talk is just the evaluation
of this energy function so I'm given a
fixed position of the nuclei in space
and the question is what is the energy
of the electronic States as a function
of these nuclear coordinates so there's
one part of this energy that just comes
from the interaction of the nuclei
amongst themselves but remember we're
modeling these nuclei as these classical
point particles there's this very simple
Coulomb interaction between them this is
trivial to calculate the harder part is
this electronic contribution to the
energy and it's harder because you know
these electrons are in some quantum
mechanical States and so the main goal
of quantum chemistry the thing else then
almost all of the rest of the talk
talking about is finding the ground
states of this electronic Hamilton so we
fixed the the positions of the nuclei
they exert some fun they exert some
forces on the electrons and we want to
find the lowest energy states of these
electrons subject to this Hamiltonian
and it'll turn out that this Hamiltonian
has a nice form once we've spent some
time developing the formalism and
explaining where these coefficients come
from and and what these funny operators
are because they're not the normal cubed
operators that that were used to say
so to start with a very simple example
you know consider the states of the
single electron it can be described by
this wave function in real space in r3
or it's a quantum state so it's
normalized but this wave function is
this infinite dimensional object but at
the end of the day we want to compute
something that's are represented on a
computer either classical or quantum
mechanically and so we need to
discretize we need to somehow make our
our representation of the system finite
and we do that by introducing this
finite basis of the wave function and in
this context I'll call these one
electron basis functions orbitals and
I'll use this word you know many times
throughout the talk you know orbitals
are just these one electron basis
functions and so you know given some
wave function we can at least
approximately write it in this basis of
one electron basis and if we do that you
know we can you know rewrite this more
physics looking expression as something
that we're familiar this is just a big
end level acute
but note that this approximation could
be good or it could not be so good and
so now we've introduced what is our
first non negligible approximation where
we've taken this infinite infinite
dimensional space and approximated if I
find a dimensional one and so the
difference between these two things is
called the basis set error so it's the
difference between you know the true
ground state energy the ground state of
this full infinite dimensional
Hamiltonian and the ground the best the
lowest energy state within the space
spanned by our finite number of basis
functions and this choice of basis
functions is not arbitrary you know
depending on the system you know we'll
have some sense of what the ground state
should look like at least qualitatively
and we'll want to choose our basis
functions so that we can capture as much
of that ground state using a smaller
number of these basis functions as
possible and a huge part of classical
computational chemistry is finding good
basis functions so that we can as
concisely as possible represent the the
ground state that systems of interest
so now I'm moving on to two electrons so
now we have a wave function that's a
function of just the position of these
two things in space and again we
introduced this one electron finite
basis we use the same basis for each
electron so the wave function of these
two electrons we can write again at
least approximately in a basis of tensor
products of these one electron intervals
there one electron basis and so again
you know we can rewrite this physics
looking expression in something that's
familiar to us which is you know two and
level qubits but the problem now is that
you know we're talking about a physical
system and in fact these electrons are
identical they're they're completely
indistinguishable it doesn't make sense
to say that the first electron is in
some states and the second electron is
in some other state so and we need to
you know enforce this into the
wavefunction mathematically this means
that the wave function must be either
symmetric or anti-symmetric when we
permutes the particles and so at this
level of the theory you know we'll just
need to take it as a rule you know it
can be derived at deeper levels but at
this point it's just an assumption that
we're going to make that electrons are
what's called fermions which my
definition means that the type of
particle for which the wave function
must be anti-symmetric as opposed to
symmetric and you know operationally
what that means is that we need to
restrict our attention to the minus one
eigen space of the swap operator so that
when we swap the state of the two qubits
we pick up the sign but otherwise leave
the state unchanged so you know we saw
that we can write our system as the
general states of Q 2 Q tits but now
we're going to look at a smaller state
of spanned by you know anti-symmetric
combinations of unique indices and you
know emphasize at this point too that
you know these pairs of indices are
unique because this anti symmetry zation
property implies that no more than one
electron can be in any particular state
because
when we applied the swap operator you
know if there were two things in the
same state we would get that the
coefficient is equal to minus itself
into zero and this is known as the Pauli
exclusion principle and so this this
suggests that maybe there's a different
way of representing our state instead of
talking about the states of individual
particles we'll just talk about the
occupations of states so we can start to
index our states by these bit strings
with in this case exactly two ones in
them which just say which orbitals have
electrons in them but this
representation you know directly
captures the fact that these are
indistinguishable indistinguishable
particles you know it doesn't say which
electron is in which state just as these
are States and they have electrons in
them this is a very concrete example you
know suppose we have two electrons and
four orbitals you know so on the one
hand and this particle representation we
have this basis of anti-symmetric
combinations of unique indices but it
corresponds in this occupation
representation to bitstrings with
exactly two zeros and so you know for
two electrons and four orbitals we get
these four choose two or six basis
elements of this space and this is just
a real labeling of things right so we we
saw that we have to have this anti
symmetries ation and so it makes sense
to you know start to throw away
information about which electron is
which and have our notation you know
more concisely capture the nature of the
system
and now we can start to generalize this
to an arbitrary number of electrons so
you know the first pass we have just a
set of many lot large dimensional Q
dates but again we need to restrict
ourselves to this anti-symmetric
subspace and so for a general set of n
electrons this means that for every pair
of qubits we need to restrict our
attention to the minus one audience
basis of the swap operator for all of
these qubits and so again you know we're
restricting our attention to this anti
symmetrized space which we can you know
iterate over by looking at all sets of
unique indices in all permutations of
these indices with the addition of a
plus or minus 1 depending on the parity
of the permutation and this should
strike you is very familiar because this
is exactly the form that determinant
state and indeed you know there's this n
by n matrix that I can write down where
the columns correspond to particles and
the rows correspond to orbitals such
that you know these basis states are
exactly determinants of matrices of that
form but again you know this is a little
complicated it obscures what's going on
and so we have this alternative
occupation representation in terms of
bit strings with exactly some number of
ones in them which say you know which
orbitals are occupied by some electron
and so you know given this occupation
representation you know I explained what
the states represent but now we need to
start operating within this space and so
we define what's called an annihilation
operator and this annihilation operator
takes bit strings to bit strings or yeah
states index like that strings to States
index by bit strings and there's an
annihilation operator for every orbital
and so if we you know act with an
annihilation operator on a state that
has an electron in that particular
orbital represented by this one it
knocks down the occupation number to
zero but it also introduces this anti
Semitism factor that depends on the
occupation of some other set of rules so
note that this occupation representation
you know by construction represents the
indistinguishability of these particles
but the fact that it's anti-symmetric
rather than symmetric it comes into the
way that we operate on these states and
keep track of the relative sign between
these bases things and you know on the
other hand if we act with this
annihilation operator on a state that
doesn't have a particle and the
corresponding orbital the operator
completely extinguishes this thing
because there's no particle and that
that orbital to to remove and we can
also look at the hermitian conjugate of
the annihilation operator called the
creation operator which says the
opposite so if we act on it with it on a
state that doesn't have an electron in
that orbital it bumps up the occupation
number to one again with this anti
symmetry zation factor but to react with
the creation operator on a state that
does have an electron and that's that
orbital then it completely extinguishes
that's big and this again comes from the
fact that these represent anti symmetry
state and there can be no more than one
particle in each
and so we can start to combine these
operators and you know the first thing
we can do is create what's called a
number operator which just takes out the
number of particles in each orbital
which will just be 0 no 1 and we can
also look at other combinations of these
things so particular if we take a
creation operator an annihilation
operator and we look at the anti
commutator we get one yeah so the way
you wrote these it looks like the
creation and annihilation operators are
not local with respect to the bulls is
that the case yeah yeah and I'll get to
that later because that introduces some
complication when we want to represent
these states in a state of qubits so
this looks like a set of qubits all
right because I have these states that
I'm indexing by strings but these are
not qubits these are fermionic states
and you know so we have these right so
it looked like non-local operators and
that work will will require addressing
when we want to represent these as
qubits and manipulate them in the
spatial sense because look local
well it's non-local in the general sense
and the number of things that it acts on
non trivially which you know implies
that it's not local in the geometric
but we'll return to that very explicit
I'll give some constructions about how
we address them but that's is one of the
you know it's a good question because it
gets at one of the main differences
between these fermionic hamiltonians and
in general cutit Hamiltonian so we have
a Hamiltonian that looks local right so
I wrote it as the sum of these things
over some small number of indices but
these operators are non-local in some
order so the big P and Q are our vectors
right no but thank you know they're just
single numbers between 1 and big n Oh
any intuition for why does that or
during that that when you annihilate
at site P that it only cares about the
occupation so this is yeah so this is
completely a convention so you know we
have these these [ __ ] stirrings that
represent you know occupation vectors
let's say you know which orbitals have
electrons in them but what's important
is that we keep track of if we look back
at you know the correspondence between
these bitstrings and the anti
symmetrized product there's this you
know sign in front of the permutations
that is the parity of that permutation
and really if you think about it you
know what matters is not the parity of
any particular permutation with the
relative parity of different
permutations and so the the fact that
this sign is only a function of some
some occupation numbers and not others
is really just a convention that you
know we choose some ordering of the
orbitals so that we can consistently
keep track of the relative sign of these
things so it and implicitly when I say
that we have this bit string in this
occupation basis there's an ordering of
things right so I'm saying that you know
the first orbital is the first v the
second orbital is the second bit and you
know the ordering is completely
arbitrary as long as I'm consistent
the other questions
yeah so okay so we define the this
number operator and then we can look at
this anti commutator and you know it
turns out that it's one because no
matter what the occupation number is in
the p orbital you know when we act on it
by this anti symmetric or this anti
commutator one of these terms will be
zero and the other term will return the
state gun change so no matter what we we
stay we act on it with we get one the
state returned and so now we can look at
combinations of annihilation operators
corresponding to different orbitals and
again we see that the anti symmetry is
manifest in the way these operators
interact with each other
so that if we switch the ordering of
these operators we get a minus sign but
but otherwise things are unchanged and
you know in a sense of the fact that the
minus sign is here rather than here
comes from this I'm just picking some
ordering and you know in whatever
indexing scheme I've chosen you know say
P is less than Q or vice versa and as
long as I'm consistent things will work
out but but in some sense there's an
arbitrary choice I make to be
it's over all we can you know very
succinctly describe the the relationship
between these operators in what's called
this fermionic algebra so this very
succinctly commutation relationships and
it will be also useful later on to think
of this identification between these
[ __ ] strings these occupation vectors
and the set of creation operators that
when we apply to the vacuum state for
the state with no particles in it
creates this occupation vector and so
you know if these things were to commute
you know we can think of this as just a
multinomial polynomial or sorry multi
linear polynomial but they don't commute
to it we need to be careful about the
sign but it will be useful it'll be
useful later when we talk about
interchanging basis and stuff to to have
this picture in mind
so now we can get back to the
Hamiltonian that we care about but laws
of physics tell us that if we have these
these point charges and we have the set
of electrons this is what the
Hamiltonian gives this we have no
control over and the Hamiltonian has
three different parts so one is the
kinetic energy of the electrons the
second is the the Coulomb or
electromagnetic interaction between the
electrons and the nuclei and the last is
the via Coulomb interaction between
pairs of electrons in an instance of the
problem that we're interested in is
defined by three very simple parameters
we have the set of nuclear positions you
know this set of vectors in r3 we have
the nuclear charges which just counts
how many protons are in each nucleus you
know what is the charge of the nucleus
and how many electrons we have and note
that you know all of the electrons are
identical so the only thing that matters
is how many there are there's no sense
of first electrons second electron
but then again you know this is defined
in this infinite dimensional space and
so we'll need to pick some finite
dimensional basis in which we represent
this Hamiltonian and so we do that and
you know which orbitals we choose can
make a big difference but we choose one
and then we can calculate the
representation of the Hamiltonian in
this basis we get these coefficients
these tensors whose elements come altom
utley from you know integrals over these
energy functions of the individual one
electron basis functions and so we get
back to the Hamiltonian that I started
with it and said that you know I would
explain why it has this format and where
these coefficients come
so this is representing the Hamiltonian
what's called the occupation basis so we
have this one body term that corresponds
to things having to do with a single
electron
the kinetic energy and the interaction
with the nuclei and we have this two
body term that corresponds to things
having to do with two electrons namely
the Coulomb interaction between them and
you know this is very nice it looks
local in some sense but but as we talked
about earlier it's it's non-local in
another sense in a way that we'll need
to address and importantly it's anti
symmetries by construction but note that
it's still chioma hard right so if we
were to look in the particle
representation that is not inherently
anti symmetrize we would say you know
we're trying to find the lowest energy
state subject to this anti semitism
condition and so we're restricting our
attention to a smaller part of this
space and it's Porton to note that like
that's without loss of hardness we can
still this still captures qma completes
Hamiltonian there is a very
straightforward mapping reduction from a
to local qubit hamiltonian to a
Hamiltonian of this one and so even
though we've anti symmetries things
things are still hard except for the
fact that you know these coefficients
come from these integrals of a very
particular form and so maybe you know
there's some structure here that we can
exploit at least heuristic way maybe we
can say we'll find the ground state
you know there's some structure that we
can start to get some intuition with it
and develop good approximations for and
another difference from the you know
generic local hamiltonians is that well
normally when we're talking about local
hamiltonians we imagine we have a large
number of particles with a small local
dimension but here generally and
especially for the types of instances
that we think quantum computers will be
most helpful for the the situation is a
little reversed so we have some small
number of particles you know tens of
electrons or something like that
but the number of orbitals our local
dimension is much much higher it's
orders of magnitude higher and so you
know this isn't technically inconsistent
with our general idea of local
hamiltonians but it has you know
qualitatively different flavor that may
use require different techniques this is
a good place to stop and ask if there
are any questions you know this is as
much as I'll say about you know the
problem that we're trying to solve
yeah you mentioned on the previous slide
all right actually right there um the
you're interested in the situation where
the number of orbitals is much greater
than the number of electrons I mean
what's the motivation that's essentially
said so I'm a quantum chemist so what's
the motivation for kind of focusing in
on that because typically I think about
quantum computers being most useful or
strongly correlated systems is normally
around the case where you've got you
know like half occupancy so similar
number of electrons and orbitals where
this gap so this is this is not an
absolute statements there generally was
you know it's I wrote it down
consciously to say that you know this is
not absolutely the case but yeah I mean
I think it's yeah it is probably helpful
to identify that as that is the common
cases yeah yeah this is not this is
definitely not always the case
yeah and generally you know especially
if you're a quantum chemist a lot of the
things I'm saying might grab your
attention because you know I I'm
simplifying a lot of things and sweeping
a lot of exceptions and technicalities
under the rug so now I'll say a very
little bit about classical approaches so
the the starting point of classical
methods is often usually what's called
hartree-fock so a very high level the
hartree-fock state is the best set of n
electron orbitals or more precisely it's
the state in which you know the best and
electra single electron orbitals are
occupied and so to start to get some
sense of what this means suppose that we
only had a single electron and we could
ignore the you know electron-electron
interactions and we asked what are the
end lowest energy levels of this single
electron and because there's only one
electron you know we can easily
calculate this and get the N lowest
energy states and now suppose that we we
brought back in all of the other
electrons and we populated these n
lowest energy single electron States
let's do this you know once we've
reintroduced the electron-electron
interaction this will probably not still
be a good approximation of the ground
state you know somehow this electron
electron interaction is very important
to consider it so what hartree-fock does
in a sense is it does better by
considering at least on average the
effect of these other orbitals and
there's some set of couple of equations
that we can iterate through to get to
get this mean field approximation of the
best single end single electron for
reals
there's a little bit more formally you
know what what does it mean to change
the basis so in the particle
representation it just means that we're
going to apply this rotation to each of
the qubits individually and in the
occupation representation what we're
doing is we're applying this rotation to
the creation operators we're gonna
rights our creation our new creation
operators these eight Tilda's as linear
combinations of the old ones and our
goal with hartree-fock is to find this
rotation such that we can find the best
single determinant this single bit
string in this new basis that has the
lowest energy and this won't always be
you know the ground state in general it
won't be but it's often extremely close
and this is you know it's often
surprisingly close and even when it's
not exactly at the ground state it's a
very good starting point and it's why
it's the hartree-fock is the first thing
I introduced because for both classical
and quantum computational methods you
know hartree-fock is the starting point
and we have we get very close to the
ground state and then we want to use you
know more advanced methods that gets a
little bit closer and note that I was
talking about this hartree-fock state
but you know we're optimizing over this
basis and so really with this
hartree-fock basis in which without loss
of generality by convention we can just
say the hartree-fock States is you know
ones followed by zeros but we have this
new basis that we're starting to work in
and so the first you know next step we
we can start to take from hartree-fock
is what's called configuration
interaction and so you know recall the
Hamiltonian it has this form where there
are these one body terms that take an
electron out of one orbital and put it
in another and there's this two body
term that takes a pair of electrons out
of orbitals and puts them in new ones
and so this induces some sort of metric
on the space of bit strings that's you
know proportional to the Hamming
distance between these bit strings and
so we can start to look at states that
are near hartree-fock under this metric
so you know there are some set of
orbitals that are occupied in
hartree-fock and some set that aren't
and so we consider say singles where we
take a single electron out of the
occupied States and put it in an
unoccupied one and you know we can look
at doubles and triples and so on and you
know as we increase the number of
excitations are willing to consider away
from hartree-fock you know we're
incorporating a larger and larger
portion of our hell Brut space and so
our approximation of the ground state
will be getting and better but at the
cost of getting more and more expensive
because we're you know keeping track of
more and more states and in the limits
when we consider an arbitrary number of
excitations away from our Chi 5 we get
what's called full configuration
interaction which is essentially exactly
diagonalizing up to the base of Center
and so this is the gold standard of
quantum chemistry calculations exactly
because you know we're diagonal is
diagonal diagonalizing in essentially
the whole space but of course you know
this comes at the cost of being
extremely expensive and so we only
really do FCI for relatively small sizes
and there are other ways of you know
trying to find the important parts of
the hilbert space to search over so
there's a class of methods called
adaptive sampling where we start with
some small set of determinants we look
at you know a larger set that's nearby
that's connected to it through the
Hamiltonian and so we've increased the
size of our representation and hopefully
improved our approximation of the ground
phase well we can't keep doing this
right there's only so many determinants
that we can keep track of so what we do
is we diagonalized in this larger space
and we look at what the most important
parts are and we throw away the rest and
so we return to a new small set of
determinants that's hopefully a little
better than the one we started with when
we can iterate this on you know expand a
little bit optimize throw away the the
negligible parts and you'll repeat this
over and over and so empirically you
know this has been shown to work
extremely well and it's interesting in
you know to compare with algorithms that
have been developed in the context of
the ground states of 1d hamiltonians
where we have these matrix product
states that are these bounded size
classical descriptions of an
approximation to the ground state we you
know use the Hamiltonian to see what is
nearby in this hour our putative onsets
we get this larger and better
approximation of the ground state but
then we need to truncate in some way and
so there's this process of you know
increasing the size and accuracy of our
representation and truncation back and
forth truncating back and forth in a way
that you know hopefully converges and in
that case we can prove it does
so that was in some sense a complete
injustice to two classical methods you
know very very simplistic introduction
to it to what classical computational
approaches to quantum chemistry are and
it's important to say that classical
computational methods in quantum
chemistry have been enormous ly
successful there are many you know very
large interesting systems that are very
useful that have been solved extremely
well but the problem is that there is
yeah big round states are not very yeah
yeah so that's sort of what I was just
getting at is that the the systems for
which these classical methods work very
well are systems for which you can
describe the ground state to a very good
approximation by some reasonable number
of determinants so it's not exactly
unentangled but it's lacking what's
called strong correlation and it's
exactly those instances for which that's
not a reasonable description that we
hope to use quantum computers because
instead of keeping track of this state
of the system as this you know classical
representation this list of amplitudes
in some basis you know we're going to
just create the state on our quantum
computer and let you know mother nature
keep track of the amplitudes for us
would an example be for example of the
molybdenum cofactor or the iron cofactor
in these enzymes that have strong
correlations or are those cases that you
think are adequately simulated with
classical tools I I don't know I'm not
familiar with that system someone who
works with these things more detail
testing yeah so so another thing I
should say at this point is that the
next talk later this afternoon will be
by Alec who who will say a lot more
detail about classical computational
approaches to quantum chemistry are very
successful except for in the some cases
they're nothing and they'll say
hopefully a lot more detail about you
know where where that line is so very
simply you know the what it means to do
quantum chemistry on a quantum computer
is that we try to create this ground
state on our quantum computer and so
there are a few elements that go into
doing this so the first thing is that we
need to map the the state of the
electrons to the states of our qubits
and then we need to do something that
you know has the effect of preparing the
ground state and we heard a lot about
that this morning I won't say much more
than to you know review the the
techniques that were explained earlier
well it's all emphasize a little bit
about you know some special cases for
quantum chemistry
so the the first thing I'll talk about
is this this mapping between fermionic
States and qubit States so on the one
hand you know both states are indexed by
these bit strings and so you know it may
seem like what what's the problem why
don't we just map it
but suppose that we were just to to do
this this identity mapping where we mesh
drink to the same [ __ ] drink but recall
that we have this annihilation operator
that looks very non-local or if it has
this this parody that depends on the
occupation of some other set of orbitals
and so one way the Jordan Vigna encoding
of mapping this fermionic operator to a
qubit operator is like this we have some
string of Z's that acts on the lower
indexed qubits with this thing that has
the effect of moving from the one state
to the zero States on the P cubed and
it's exactly the string of Z's that
accounts for this this parody up here
and you know I won't go through the
details here but you can show that you
know if we do the mapping in this way
then these encoded qubit operators oh
baby the the fermionic algebra that we
should they have the same anti
commutation relationships then as the
the fermionic operators that death and
map from
and you'll note that if we do this
mapping and we start with this to body
fermionic Hamiltonian and we encode it
as a cubed operator in this way we get
these and local cubed hamiltonians which
is not good in a certain sense but it's
not as bad as it may seem so on the one
hand we can still efficiently measure
the energy of this thing these things
because although it's an local these n
local operators are strings of single
qubit or tensor products of single qubit
pulleys and so you know in one way of
thinking about is that there's like a
very simple MPO description of what what
these Hamiltonians are but there are
some complications when we want to you
know say do time evolution er is
otherwise manipulate the states in a way
that's expressed using these operators
and sometimes it turns out for you know
many systems of interests there are some
tricks that we can do where you know
this overhead sort of sort of goes away
but still it's you know it's a
complication that that needs to be
addressed
so an alternative way of representing
the states is what's called the parody
encoding where you know before you know
we saw that this nonlocality comes from
the fact that you know we have this
minus one that depends on the occupation
of some other set of fermions
there are orbitals and so we can ask you
know okay why don't we just represent
that you know and use the our qubits to
represent that and the problem is that
if we do that now the you know the
parity is encoded locally but now the
occupation is non-local and so we've
sort of flipped things you know whereas
before we had some string of Z's on the
left followed by some local operator now
we have some local operator followed by
some string of X's and so you know we
flips things in a way that doesn't
change much of interest we still get
this and local Hamiltonian when we map
from a fermionic operator Hamiltonian to
a cubed operator
unfortunately you know there are some
intermediate ways so there's what's
called the bravi kitaev encoding which
Maps the fermionic States these cubed
states in you know very clever way and I
won't go into the detail of exactly
what's going on here but the points is
that the end result is that when we take
our two body fermionic Hamiltonian and
we represent it as a cubed operator
using the bra V kitaev encoding what we
get is a log local Hamiltonian which is
much improved in terms of something to
manipulate our state using the
primitives that are expressed in terms
of these operators this was a you know
very non exhaustive survey of you know
different approaches for doing these
fermion to keep it mappings and there's
like a very large and growing body of
work that has some very nice
generalizations and extensions of these
types of ideas where you know some of
these are locality preserving for you
know fermionic systems to find on
lattices and may be of interest of
people here is that some of these
encoding x' have err corrective
properties so it's not only an encoding
of the fermionic states in the fermionic
algebra but for example this minor on a
loop stabiliser code also has the
property that it corrects up to single
qubit errors and so there's this nice
intersection between this fermionic
algebra and quantum error correction
that might be a good entry point into
quantum chemistry for first a quantum
computer scientist who's maybe not
familiar with physics or
so having you know talked about how we
represent the state of our electrons on
our quantum computer now we need to
start talking about you know how we're
going to prepare this ground state and
you know I won't tread any new ground
here it'll really just be a review of
what we heard this morning so one way is
variational e right so we have some
parameter I circuit you know we have
these classical parameters theta these
little knobs on RN gates that we can
play around with and try to optimize and
produce the lowest energy state that we
can and it's variational in the sense
that you know no matter how we set these
knobs we'll always get an upper bound to
our ground States and so we'll never
know that we got our ground state for
sure
but we will know that we never overshoot
it we never go below the ground state
energy and as was mentioned before you
know how we find these parameters is is
a big open question but this is also a
place where classical ideas that we know
from classical computation of quantum
chemistry can give us a huge head start
so for example you know we can use as an
initial State this hartree-fock state
that we know is already very close to
the ground state and so we're not in
what would be the hopeless case of not
doing anything about the system we know
that we can get very close to the ground
state and maybe we can variational e
just get you know that much closer to
the ground state and improve the
accuracy of our approximation just that
much more so particularly we can use
what's called unitary coupled cluster
which is this very you know chemistry
motivated on sides so it uses structure
from the Hamiltonian in particular you
know the onsets is the exponential of
what's called a cluster operator which
has these one and two body terms that
look very much like terms of the
Hamiltonian the except instead of coming
from the true physics of the problem
these coefficients are parameter
variational parameters they're exactly
the knobs that we can start to tune to
try to find as low and underneath state
does it
and you know maybe we can't do this
exactly about we approximately another
approach that we saw earlier this
morning was quantum phase estimation so
you know suppose that we were given in
eigenstates of the system and we want to
measure the we want to estimate the
energy of the eigenvalue or more
precisely the exponent of the iodine
quantum phase estimation is a very
simple quantum circuit that allows us to
do this so if we feed in you know some
ancillary register and this inputs
eigenstates
quantum phase estimation gives us an
estimate to some you know finite
precision of what this energy is but of
course you know we we don't necessarily
have the exact ground state that we want
and so in general if we feed in an
arbitrary state we get the ground state
energy you know up to it's a finite
precision with probability that's
proportional to the overlap with the
ground state energy and this is another
case in which the fact that classical
methods can get us extremely close to
the ground state is of interest because
if we just had an arbitrary state you
know this would be hopeless we would
just be getting random noise from from
our quantum computer but if we know that
we can start with a ground since they
are sorry an approximate wave function
that has very good overlap with the
ground state then there's this hope that
you know with high probability this
procedure will project us into the
actual ground faith and we can estimate
the energy there and there's been some
very nice numerical work recently
showing that you know for many systems
of interest we can actually make this
overlap pretty good and that this is a
very promising approach you know down
the road when we have computers that can
actually implement these things or for
finding the COTS state
again as we heard before you know
another way of preparing these ground
states is adiabatic Li alright so we
want to prepare some ground states so we
start in the ground states of some
easy-to-prepare
initial Hamiltonian for example you know
a simple Hamiltonian whose ground state
is hartree-fock and we evolved for some
time interpolating between this initial
Hamiltonian and Hamiltonian whose ground
state we will occupy and in general you
know this is complete for quantum
computation this this could take a very
long time but we can hope that you know
if we start close enough to the ground
states of the Hamiltonian that we care
about you know maybe maybe the general
worst case results aren't necessarily
applicable and that the instances that
we care about won't be we won't be
pathological that that the the path
between the initial state from the final
state will be relatively short but of
course this is a heuristic and it
remains to be seen empirically and the
last thing is that you know in the
previous algorithms I sort of assumed
that as a primitive we have the ability
to do time evolution you know given a
Hamiltonian evolve the states under the
action of this Hamiltonian and there are
many different ways of doing this you
know a simple way is called the product
formula where you know imagine the terms
of this local Hamiltonian commuted then
we can just simply apply the product of
the Exponential's of the individual
terms they don't commute but it's a
reasonable approximation to do it like
this where we evolve a little bits under
each term in sequence and then we
repeats over and over again and so we
sort of stroboscopic Li approximate the
evolution of this whole Hamiltonian and
in the past there's been a very wide gap
between you know bounds that we can show
on the error of this approximation
analytically and what we saw in practice
that is empirically we saw that this is
a much better approximation that we can
prove it is and very recently in the
past few weeks as we said earlier you
know there's been some very nice work
that you know takes into account in in
very careful ways the relationship
between these terms in a way that makes
this
approach you know competitive with other
recent advanced algorithms things like
quantum singular value transformation
that's a beautiful general algorithm one
of whose applications is this task of
Hamiltonian simulation and we'll hear a
lot more about that in detail later in
the week from other so to conclude you
know I've hopefully given the sense that
you know mainly quantum chemistry about
is it's about finding the ground state
of a specific type of Hamiltonian you
know classical methods can get us
classical computational methods can get
us very good approximations using
heuristics that are you know
well-founded physically and you know
validated empirically but still there
are systems for which they don't get
quite as accurate as we like them to and
these are the instances for which we can
start to use quantum computers and we
can try to set up the ground state of
the Hamiltonian on our quantum computers
and then these different aspects that go
into do that that you interact in subtle
ways so for example there are basis sets
that we can choose that will yield some
structure in the Hamiltonian that we
could exploit algorithmically but we
also need to be careful that the basis
sets that we choose you know are
appropriate to the instances that we're
looking at that with some reasonable
number of them we could well approximate
the ground state and overall you know
progress can be made by looking at you
know trade-offs between these things and
trying to improve parameters and the
relationship between them and overall
you know I've really I've given you a
sense of why quantum chemistry is a very
interesting and useful domain to start
to apply these advances that have been
made in quantum algorithms on the
increasingly larger and better quantum
computers that are being built
[Applause]
the interaction terms with electrons
yeah so I mean that example you can
write this isn't it the whole point if I
change it on hartree-fock correctly it
seems like essentially what the
algorithm is doing is so if you so you
have that Coulomb the Coulomb
interaction rate and also that comes
from another variational problem which
is just minimizing the energy of the
classical electric field with the
charges at particular places so you
could just you can essentially think of
perfect if I'm just alternating between
solving the classical field to find a
single field then you're considered the
Hamiltonian that that has no
electron-electron interaction terms but
it has it's an arbitrary field and then
so I'm not sure that that's quite right
- I mean it's not quite exactly that
you're throwing away the
electron-electron interaction
you're just incorporating it in some
average it's not quite that there's no
interaction between the electrons
there's maybe a different way of
hartree-fock state as the exact ground
state of something similar to the actual
Hamiltonian but instead you see we throw
away all the electron-electron
interaction terms but you add a term
which is electrons to now an arbitrary
field in addition to the ones generated
by the nuclei where yeah so I mean the
hartree-fock states in the hartree-fock
basis is just a you know a single bit
string and so of course there's a very
simple hamiltonian of which this is the
ground state but it's not exactly the
you know it's that's not exactly how we
find the hartree-fock basis
yeah so I mean maybe another way of
saying it kind of one of the ways that
we think about it as chemists is that
you do basically seek out a potential
kind of like what you're talking about
you know through the optimization you go
and find an effective one particle
operator that's self consistent with
that and and you know as chemists wealth
and say work your [ __ ] self-consistent
field interchangeably you would you know
actually chemistry thesaurus would show
in fact the case that the hartree-fock
is exactly the state it's finding is
exactly the ground state of something
where you get rid of the two electron
for actions just have an electron in
some arbitrary field and then you find
the field corresponding to the average
positions and well like yeah like what
he was saying wait we don't quite get
rid of the two electron integrals we
just treat them in a mean field an
average way such that you isn't that the
same part are they the same thing I
don't know if the difference right here
is just language or but all of the and
maybe we can follow up after but it is
folded in in an effective average way
yes
you start with a Hamiltonian that is
that is commonly used for chemicals
problems chemistry and then we use it to
a qubit Hamiltonian at some point will I
be able to guess it came from one of
these chemistry yes that's a very good
question I think probably not I mean at
least not obviously I mean it has you
know the it's similar to all of these
other situations where reduce you know
Hamiltonian of one sort to a Hamiltonian
of another sort and you know we get some
special subset of the Hamiltonians and
the target space but it's maybe not so
easy to recognize that this is the case
so it would be interesting to consider
that itself as a computational problem
but let me just say one more thing about
that it's like it's very important to
remember that we did this transformation
and not to think of things and the Cupid
thing but to really think about things
and the concise representation that they
came through a lot is obscured when like
if I wanted to express the Hamiltonian
to you I would express it in the
fermionic representation I wouldn't you
know translate it to a Cupid operator
and give it to you and say yeah this is
you know a bravia kitaev encoded
Hamiltonian in this basis you know it
would lose it would obscure a lot of
things that you could otherwise probably
take advantage to kind of set the ground
state for some of the qubits and then do
the configuration interaction using
phase estimation or would it not would
there be like no potential use case for
wanting to combine the approaches yeah I
think got all of the approaches that
that I mentioned could be you know
combined in in arbitrary ways and yeah
so I'm not sure exactly what you were
proposing but there are methods where
you know we fix parts of the hilbert
space and we try to optimize over the
other ones and in fact you know when we
look at doing things on a quantum
computer oftentimes you know we do some
first approximation on a classical
computer of you know a very large system
and then we notice that you know there's
some central core that strongly
correlated and it's only that central
core that that we represent on the
quantum computer and the you know the
effect of the other electrons that we
fixed is fixed is introduced in the
classic
what if you thought about quantum
embeddings and the promise for that
approach I don't know
that's something I've only recently been
looking at and yeah I haven't fully
appreciated you know what what what the
the promises and challenges are it's
definitely an interesting yeah different
question then you've presented things
like Clarky Falk in the second quantized
picture how often is the first
quantization picture used in classical
quantum chemistry simulations in
comparison or is second quantization the
dominant approach so I defer to to
someone who does on a daily basis a
classical computational chemistry but I
will say that well I focused on second
quantization there are cases when
applying quantum computers that the
first quantized right there first yeah
the first quantized representation is
also useful so there's this very nice
example in using the plane wave basis
where if you look in the first quantized
representation you know get this
enormous saving in the number of qubits
that you need because you you can
represent the state in binary and you
know this is always the case but now
because it's the plane only basis you
can actually compute on this basis
because the the basis is indexed by
these momentum states and so you can
implement things like the kinetic energy
not like the index is not just some
arbitrary label it's literally you know
in a binary representation the momentum
and so you can actually compute the you
can compute the parts of the Hamiltonian
as opposed to just looking them up or
using Q RAM or whatever and so there are
definitely cases where it's very useful
to look at first
so in this particular case you know it's
not so hard to set up the hartree-fock
States in in first quantization you know
there there are nice and pretty simple
circuits that will do it for you and
then as long as you so the the
Hamiltonian you know compute commutes
with the swap operator and so you know
as long as we ensure that our initial
States is anti symmetrized and the only
thing we do is you know evolve in time
under parts of the Hamiltonian that
respect the symmetrization then it stays
symmetrized and then maybe you know at
the end we can do some error correction
you know we can see maybe this isn't
quite as symmetrized as it should be and
and try to sort of snap back to the
nearest antisymmetry state related to
that I mean have people thought about
imposing that symmetry measurement so
ignoring the fact that you have to
symmetrize your own to operate it
evolving for a little bit but then
projecting into just the symmetry
subspace yeah yeah so there's a there's
some work by that whoosh
[Music]
Reuben that looked at so I didn't have
time to talk about there's this like n
represent ability problem where you're
given like the reduced density matrix
matrices and you're interested in you
know are these consistent with each
other is there this global state and I
think that those sort of questions are
related to that's why you're asking
about but we can talk more
[Applause]